you got obama's birthday party getting
cancelled no you didn't get cancer
you're talking about i mean he got
cancelled though
people are mad at him for having a
birthday party i feel like if you're old
and you're like part of the comorbidity
[ __ ] you could do whatever you want
wait why because you're the people
that's going to die
like if you want to have the super
spreader event right
you guys are just going to kill
yourselves everybody at that party is
over 60 years old and everybody was a
backstop
also most of them probably vaccinated
everyone but the issue now isn't oh yeah
just because you're vaccinated it
doesn't matter you could get it then you
could spread it to people who are not
vaccinated
so i guess i guess people are saying
it's hypocritical because he support you
know supposed to support whatever the
dems say and the dems are like don't do
these types of events and make sure you
mask up et cetera but he's also on his
hawaiian [ __ ] he was out there with the
puka shell necklace
yeah i'm done with this politics [ __ ]
like everybody come on over let's get it
that's the worst part about being the
president i feel like back in the day
you could stop being the president and
you could just kick it people loved you
like they didn't take what you said that
seriously you could just live like
[ __ ] george bush was painting and
[ __ ] yeah but now if you're the
president you stop you still gotta be
the president
you know yeah because if you stay
involved if you're doing speeches if
you're campaigning people i guess it's
on him that's the thing like he's so
powerful that the party needs him but
low-key once you do your time you do
that eight years
you know what i mean you rack up a few
i don't know 100 000 kills
that's a fact bro this guy hates
gathering so much like he scaled down
his gathering by like hundreds like yeah
in the middle east he scaled down a lot
of those gatherings like this guy hates
gatherings just across the street
true it's really true man like that's
not the first gathering that he's uh
yeah he's decreased by a lot and
weddings out there bro yeah you get an
invitation to a yemeni wedding bro
we're a hard hat
you gotta love that person to go there
that's got to be family if i'm not in
the grocery party like
yeah yeah i'm not a plus one yeah ain't
nobody going to get many weddings plus
one
my name got to be on an invitation no
alcohol what are you going to do just
show up and hang out that's right
yeah that's just wow like a childhood
pool party like you're just chilling it
really is dude oh yeah yeah crazy yeah
the crazy thing about the
he scaled down so that it's like a bunch
of people got uninvited yeah that [ __ ]
would hurt all the uninvited people got
to feel
you're like damn i'm the second class
friend or whatever the case is one name
and i'm curious if it is david david
axelrod who's the person that has run
his campaign since he was a senator for
going for election like made him yeah
and chrissy teigen's still still
chrissy teigen was invited not david
axelrod i wonder like we don't know was
he uninvited
i mean i would
not crave it
david axelrod
david
but he's not running anymore so you
don't need them
but you need john legend there to sing
them hits yeah he's going to work yeah
legends
you know start tapping
yo imagine you hire chrissy teigen and
john like teagan got to cook like you
know you got all these books out here
and so you got how nice a chef you are
go make some dumplings or some [ __ ] we
need some hors d'oeuvres to pass around
and then john legend got to start saying
it yeah let's go happy birthday both
versions
let's go john that's true he just
invited people that could also do things
that this motherfucker's the ultimate
politician yeah shouts to barry bro he's
i like this move he's like yo it's my
60th birthday i'm doing it i'm turning
it up son i respect it
i think the only pushback is when you
hear the party say different things or
you have the party completely silent or
you have the news organizations could be
completely silent because you know if
trump was throwing a party or something
like that they would be super critical i
mean you just hate seeing elites do [ __ ]
that they tell you not to do that's just
what it is like like would they do the
same thing when all the democrats were
on them
but like when you see like all the
democrats on the airplane without their
mass on and it's like okay like they've
forced us to wear our mess but they
don't have to like like people just kick
this up all the time like gavin newsom
keeps his winery open yeah but when he
sends his kid at a basketball camp they
got no masks yeah all the all everyone's
business has to be shut down but you can
everyone rules for thee but not for me
and that's just what this feels like
even if it's not exactly that because
even in florida you can have a huge
birthday party yeah so like i don't like
when all the republican politicians are
[ __ ] on them being like yo you
shouldn't have this party
they should be taking the approach of
like oh like you're being hypocritical
but like have your party have fun but i
feel like that's what a lot of them are
doing right like i feel like
no i thought the approach is how at
least whenever i see it you know you'll
see like a fox news caption it's like uh
uh a politician that said mass should be
mandatory caught maskless right so
they're really just exposing the
hypocrisy of the politicians yeah that's
true on the news instead of saying that
it shouldn't be done it's like you
shouldn't be saying you shouldn't be
implementing policy that we don't like i
saw random breaks like tweets from like
representatives being like with delta
spreading obama still chooses to blah
blah it's like you're just using that
same tag your tactics should be like yo
invite me like let me pull up let's
party yeah let's get it yeah let's have
a good time i think that should be
approached versus like you trying to
cancel him even though you're trying to
have your party too yeah yeah i thought
it was just like a hypocrisy thing but
yeah i hear you man it's just annoying
we don't like seeing [ __ ] do it
it's the same thing like with your
parents you know your parents would tell
you to do certain things or not to do
certain things then you see them doing
it it's like you don't want any
authority figure to be a hypocrite
especially when they're inconveniencing
you with their hypocrisy all right like
don't put some [ __ ] rules on me that
you don't even follow we had this health
teacher in high school i remember that
used to smoke cigarettes
this [ __ ] would be telling us to be
healthy like literally saying not smoke
cigarettes like work out do all these
things like this is how you stay healthy
and then during lunch break we're seeing
her out there with some [ __ ]
parliaments just huffing and puffing
yeah and it was crazy i've never that
[ __ ] sucks my parents were like
abstinence and i was like
how did i get here yeah the [ __ ] yes
that's not fair yeah i mean yeah yeah
whatever [ __ ] it was corny
they were married they weren't there
i didn't get that as a kid
but they should have explained that how
are they supposed to explain it to you
also why are they talking about [ __ ]
with you as a kid
kids don't [ __ ] is obama the coolest
person alive
not even in the top 100 wow
everybody wanted to be at that party son
have you seen jack harlow like what is
wrong with you
yeah what are you gonna say when you
know white rappers exist the white
rappers are out here like they'll talk
obama's the coolest people not the
coolest ones
he's not i'm going to chet hanks's
birthday before obama yeah
he looked like a goofy
in his shirt bro i'm not going to lie
[Laughter]
all rappers need to stop rapping dog
because yo mickey went in on goofy
goofy my life is a movie
there's just some people gonna have no
idea
they are crying right
because they've been laughing for the
last 72 hours about this video just like
us
but mark has never laughed so hard as he
did when he was watching i love that
video bro the goofy diss track yeah yeah
mickey washed him like you don't see me
with the bars like that body it's the
reason why he's the [ __ ] logo son
of a franchise you know what i'm saying
the [ __ ] is a franchise it's not
goofy you're not going to i don't you
know it's not goofy that greets you at
disney world no it's [ __ ]
mickey right not the goofy club yeah
goofy ain't got a girl that he smashes
goofy ain't deserve a girl
mickey got minnie duck no [ __ ] here you
get a girl
he's goofy
goofy ain't no [ __ ] mickey got some
[ __ ] bro yes
mickey got [ __ ]
out here
[Applause]
you